Hm,
okay.
We're somewhere in the catskill
mountains.
I don't know exactly where we're at.
Hudson stone.
This is round tot.
We're going out to film the Russian
movie right now.
I'm playing a Russian mob boss.
No,
that's a joke.
Look at that.
Look.
That strange thing is not having
Internet,
not having Internet because it's
extremely isolating.
You've been away from it for a little
while.
What are those walls?
They're original property markers that
Dutch settlers built in the 16 hundreds.
They don't.
They aren't used now like our property
lines are on paper.
The faithful crossing archive has been
doing this for thousands of years and
you can do this.
This is all green underneath the stair,
but it's just froze.
That's the destination that we're going
to go going down there.
Oh my God,
man.
You went in there.
No fear for this gentleman is
inspiration to all of them.
Really not going to go back up because
nice.
After being in the city for a long time,
you get used to buildings and activity
and all that stuff here,
so it's sort of shocking.
It's a stunning feeling to be in
silence.
I think we all need to change
environments every once in a while,
just so that we can get out of our own
heads.
You know,
this is.
This is a wonderful place.
Fuck.
Oh.
His practice was my grandfather and
grandmother.
That's so nice.
Mild winter for when it's not too cold.